- So you, you have kids,
so are they obsessed within Encanto?
Have you seen it a ton?
- I haven't.
- [Host] Oh!
- And I don't know if they've seen it.
I don't know my kids very well.
(laughing)
- Are they older?
- [Adam] They're teenagers.
They're 13 and 15.
So, whatever they see and do,
they- I have to pry it out of them.
- [Host] Yes.
- But, we, you know, we've-
we, we used to watch everything together,
and this is right up their alley.
So I'm assuming they have seen it.
- [Host] Okay. It's so good.
- I know it, I've heard it's incredible.
So I do, I have to watch it.
- [Host] Yeah.
- Yeah. He's just Lin.
He's, he's, it's rude how talented he is.
- Yes, I know.
And she does look like the character.
- She does! It's crazy.
- I know enough to know,
that that, that's a good match.
- Your daughter seems
very organized though,
because you posted this
to-do list that she made,
which I love.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- [Host] First of all,
my daughter does this.
- [Adam] She does?
- [Host] She makes lists.
And if we don't cross them off,
she's like, we haven't done this yet.
Which is a stall tactic for bedtime.
- [ Adam] Did she get that from you?
- Yes. I'm annoyingly organized.
- Okay, good. Good.
- Yeah.
- That's good.
- Are you like that?
- No.
- No?
- [Host] Where did this come from?
- Her mother.
- Okay.
- Yeah. No, I- I, but I admire it,
and, and I wish that I had the,
the half of the brain that she has.
- Is she still this organized?
- [Adam] Absolutely.
- Wow.
- Absolutely.
- I love it.
- She's a very organized 13 year old.
- [Host] I love efficiency.
- Me too.
- So wait. That was your
daughter being organized.
So I did find this from your son.
So let's just, this is your son.
- Oh yeah.
(laughing)
- So, I'm just going
to go ahead and say it.
That's scary as hell man.
- [Adam] It is scary.
- [Host] If I came around
a corner at this store,
I would- It's, it's awesome.
- That was at Michael's, I believe and-
- Sure, as you do.
- That's right.
(laughing)
I saw this happening and
it just warmed my heart,
(laughing)
because that if, if-
- That's your son.
- If I could pull it off, I would do it.
But he did it and it freaked
people in the store out.
And I just, I couldn't get
enough. It was a proud moment.
- [Host] I just, what I relate to though
is my son dresses up,
like even when we go out,
like he was Koopa, like in Mario Brothers.
- [Adam] Oh, really?
- So he'll wear characters
like to the store.
- [Adam] Sure.
- Like, yeah. He just
thinks it's hilarious.
It's clothes, normal
clothes. He- is beneath him.
- Yeah. It's not, it's not fun
to wear normal clothes.
- He doesn't go scary though.
But that was awesome.
- That's frightening. Yes.
- If I turned the corner,
I would definitely be like-
- And I would be like,
- Who are your parents?
- I'm sorry.
But I love this.
(laughing)